[Applause]
[Music]
all right I do believe this finally gets
me caught up on DC's animated films this
is death of Superman
so coming into this I knew it had decent
reviews and a decent reception I didn't
care as far as I was concerned I had
every reason to be really really nervous
about this first of all the original
Death of Superman story which I do know
I have the trade I bought it back in the
90s you know when it was first collected
and it's not a great story in the first
place
the last time they adopted it was
Superman doomsday it wasn't great I have
not liked the new 52 version of Superman
that this DC animated version of
Superman is more based off of I have
liked almost none of the DC animated
films that have been in this continuity
that this film is a part of and the few
that I have liked have been the ones
that have had as little to do with the
Justice League characters as possible so
right everything was a red flag it's a
story I don't love with a version that I
don't like of this character and a
continuity that I've largely hated so
why is it really good like I'm I I'm
like I'm having a hard time finding
words besides that like I sat there
watching it thinking like actively
thinking this as always watching going
why why would all the other DC movies in
this continuity this good how are they
getting it so right now where they've
gotten so wrong at every stand almost
every
step of the way up to this point in a
weird way I wonder if they finally took
note of what wasn't working because with
a fair number of these characters they
seem to have found the ways that they
work better like Batman that we see here
is pretty close to the Batman that we
saw in Justice League dark ie the
deadpan humor which he's actually really
good for and you know they seemed you'll
finally found a balance with Diana they
day and flashes is fun you know this
this team is good and Superman like
Superman of all the stuff that I have
hated and I have hated a lot of stuff in
this continuity of movies I haven't had
a particular bug up my rear about this
version of Superman I've had a lot of
issues with this version of Batman I
have despised this continuities version
of Wonder Woman I've disliked a lot of
the relationships that I've hated the
way a lot of the stories have been told
Superman has a character I didn't hate
in this continuity I kinda hated new 52
Superman in the comics but that's
another thing but yeah I didn't have a
particularly guess him but he never did
much he was just kind of there he was
the guy who flew and just punched things
a lot this movie devotes a surprising
amount of time - well - doing what
basically every adaptation of this story
and I would argue even the original
version of the story has failed to do
which is before killing him firmly
grounding and establishing why this
death means something establishing the
importance of Superman to the world he
protects and to the specific people that
he loves and that love him back that so
much time
and well-paced I'm like they take they
take the time Lawton well-paced slow
character building scenes getting us to
know this version of Superman properly I
would argue for the first friggin time
in this continuity but like even you go
back to the original version you know
the comic book version of death of
Superman reading it as a story in and of
itself it doesn't give you any of that
it if it works at all is because it's
banking on decades of established
Superman continuity and it's counting on
you looking you loving and knowing why
Superman is important from that and then
just kills him and then in the times
that they've tried to adapt it before
whether its animated with Superman
doomsday they basically kill him within
the first 10-15 minutes of the movie so
they don't establish anything and again
they're kind of banking on your
pre-existing knowledge and then the way
that story was integrated or actually
not really integrated at all rather
tacked on at the end of Batman V
Superman yeah that didn't to work either
here I mean the title is the death of
Superman we know where this is going so
taking the time to show how good he is
like I'm covered not very long ago at
all one of my favorite animated Superman
films the Superman versus the elite but
this is also really good this movie gets
Superman and gets why he matters and why
he is important to why his loss is a big
loss not just because oh we have one
less defender of the earth but because
of what he means to people and it
establishes that really well and all the
characters are great the character
interactions are terrific they do an
interesting thing dynamic wise because
Lois Lane and Clark Kent are dating but
Clark hasn't told her that he's Superman
yet and that that works really well the
the showing his trepidation about
wanting to open up about that side of
himself for fear of hurting
her and then doing so right before going
off to fight the thing that's gonna kill
him it lends a tragedy it bit while
there's a tragedy anyway the guy dies
but it ups the tragedy of it it makes it
more emotional it makes it more personal
and the fights are pretty good it's it's
still like it's unfortunate baked into
the narrative that it is in my mind is
kind of disappointing that Superman dies
in what is ultimately just a big fist
fight he and a monster just mutually
beat each other to death
I I've never felt as a especially
fitting death for Superman but if
they're adapting the story is the one
they're stuck with but the action sees
were good they were what they were is
they were intense they did a really good
job of selling how powerful and how
dangerous doomsday is an issue by having
him go up against the other Justice
League characters and then later on in
his actual battle Superman doomsday
himself I'm not gonna say much about him
as a character cuz doomsday is doomsday
is not a character he's never really
well I think eventually they tried to
make him a character but he wasn't
really character for a very long time he
was effectively a natural disaster he
was a walking natural disaster he didn't
have a personality he didn't have a
character and really all you can do with
somebody like that is just build up how
dangerous he is and they do that well
here it escalates well and and watching
him take down all the other superheroes
and having the other superheroes have a
good shot at him which is actually
another thing this has over the original
comic because unfortunately the folks
who are in the Justice League at the
time of the of the desert Superman in
the comics well let me put it this way
the sort of the big heavy oh my god this
guy's really powerful was punching
Booster Gold into space yeah Booster
Gold no no offense to fans of the
character but you sell him a lot better
when he when Wonder Woman can't take
them down or the flash wielding Hawkman
mase isn't able to stop him you know
that just no offense to Booster Gold but
that just sells it better I'm sorry it
just does
so this yeah this thing really works I'm
I'm still just kind of flabbergasted
I even knowing how well reviewed this
was I had no expectation that this was
gonna work it's not perfect there is one
thing about it that doesn't work and
that thing is named Lex Luthor I don't
like this version of Luthor I actually I
don't like him at all in my mind or
seven
there are numerous valid ways to do
Luthor and have them work you can do the
Golden Age mad scientist Luthor you can
do your Machiavellian grudge-holder
Luthor you know kind of your your
Smallville version of Luthor you can do
your you know businessman thinks he owns
the world Luthor you can do your
charismatic guy who can actually you
know get people to rally around him it
was kind of the the king of the hill
until Superman showed up Lex Luthor all
these are valid all these work Weasley
whiny entitled brat Luthor doesn't work
for me i I just I found him really
really irritating and I just every time
he spoke and you know Rainn Wilson does
okay I guess for what he's being called
on to do with this version of Lex Luthor
but like every time we spoke I just have
my in my mind I thought God you know if
if Clancy Brown was saying that and they
took out the petty BS from some of his
lines this would be working so much
better and I do mean petty like this
version of Lex Luthor
walks down you know a corridor of a lab
passing scientists and just glances at
all of them and tells each and every one
of them how they suck and that they're
stupid and like he's gay
like the point of which I was like I
hate you and not like in a you're a
hateable villain way like I just hate
you I hate every time you're on screen
was like he's there's this diving team
that's going where the video that was
carrying doomsday it crashed in the
ocean so it's down there and they see
some you know some people underwater and
Luthor goes those are Atlanteans you
idiot but what there's literally no
reason for him to call this guy working
for him an idiot he's just doing it
because he's a dick
and he's like the the worst kind of
entitled little prick and like and I
kind of get the angle they're going for
that that this version of Luthor is
super entitled I just don't think that
that works not not for this character
and not in this story it doesn't add
anything to have this version that have
this take on Luthor be in this story you
know the he does it doesn't feel like
he's jealous of Superman for the for the
reasons that feel legitimate like you
getting something like all-star Superman
it feels like he's jealous of Superman
because when when when mommy said I
could have the world you know I just
really I really hated him I did it's a
shame because he is I do honestly think
the only thing that didn't work he is
the one and only weakness of this movie
and unfortunately probably needs to be
there to seed what they're likely gonna
do with reign of the supermen and as
good as this was I'm still gonna be
nervous about that when that comes out
and I guess a few months because well
because reign of the supermen wasn't
very good either
and I'm nervous that you know there's
gonna be a lot more of Lex
front-and-center
that
said the initial seeding for what I know
are going to be the pieces picked up in
rain of supermen where well put into
this story they were there organically
it felt everything everything felt like
it had a purpose in this story even
though it's going to pay off later
I think Hank Henshaw was was a great
example of that because you know he's up
in the satellite and you know he has
this whole thing it was like no I know
we're in trouble but it'll be ok
Superman will save us and it serves a
few points it shows the for some people
the blind assumption that Superman will
always save them no matter what's going
wrong and that's not always gonna happen
in addition to illustrating you know for
later payoff that Hank might always have
been just a little bit crazy
so yeah a sight replace this version of
Lex Luthor with the Superman the
animated series version of Lex Luthor
you might honestly have the best
Superman film that's been done certainly
animated with this version of Lex Luthor
it's still really good like really good
I just hate it so much but if you
haven't seen this already god I kind of
hope you uh you have because wow I was
gonna say did I talk spoilers I don't
know how much I you could consider
anything that I'd talked about to be
spoilers because again that's a
Superman's the title anyways whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a whole bunch of stuff to do there's
buttons and there's links including one
to the patreon if you feel like going
there and helping keep things going so
that'll wrap it up folks remember you're
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]